Ali Afshar: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name's Ali Afshar.
Today, I'm going to be talking
to you about to the new Google
sign in button, along
with Google Drive.
Now, I'm really excited
about this.
So this week, we launched a way
for users to sign in to
your application, authorize
their data with your
application, that comes in the
form of a button, OK, and has
a number of awesome features.
Mostly, it's a well trusted
and good thing to
have on your site.
It's branded to Google.
And when users see it, they
know that what they're
getting, the way they're logging
in, that's official
and that's good.
OK.
So it was primarily launched
for Google+.
It provides some features of
knowing the user's profile,
and also provides a really cool
feature of allowing you
to initiate an over the air
install of your application on
a mobile device when the user
is logged into the web.
So all those features
are cool.
I'm just going to show you,
quickly, today, how to get it
running for your Google
Drive API application.
So the process I'm going to
do, well, the Plus team
produced a set of really
great quick starts.
So they're just quick start
applications, which you can
clone the code from GitHub.
And you can get the code in your
language and start it.
So today we're going
to be using Python.
We're going to be using
Python and JavaScript.
Obviously, there are JavaScript
components to this.
So I'm just going to go to their
page, developers.googl
e.com/plus/quickstartpython, and
I'm going to see how we're
going to do this.
So the first thing it tells me
is that I need to install some
requirements to get
this running.
This uses the flask web
application framework, which
is something I've hacked
on a lot at this.
Like probably my favorite web
application framework.
It's very simple to get started,
and from a Google
point of view, if you something
like App Engine, you
can easily host it there.
This is just very nice because
I can run stuff from the
command line.
So as with any online,
live demos
everything could go wrong.
If that happens, that would be
really exciting and fun, so
I'm looking forward to it.
So let's have a look.
So here, we've got a shell.
Let's just clear it
and have a look.
What I've done is I've cloned
the repository.
OK.
So I haven't done it
in exactly the
order they've said.
I'm a geek.
I don't like to follow
directions.
That's fine.
So I've cloned this
repository.
And I've done a couple of the
steps at the start where I've
put in my own client ID
and client secret.
I've set my authorized
JavaScript origins.
And I've set them up to work,
already, for this.
Otherwise, we'd be going through
a few forms worth of
clicking stuff, and if you've
ever done that before, you
know how to do it.
It's very simple.
So this takes you
through that.
And let's have a look.
What's in our repository?
Well we've got a client
secrets dot JSON file.
That contains information about
your client, your client
ID, your client secret, any
redirect URIs, any origins.
All of that is configured in the
client secrets dot JSON.
You can download that directly
from the API console if you'd
like, if you don't want
to create yours.
But one is provided with a quick
start, and you just need
to modify your information.
Then we've got a script,
signin.py.
OK.
That runs the entire web app.
And then, we have some
templates, and inside
templates, there's a single
template that is the index.
OK.
So that's a bit of a mish of
HTML and JavaScript, but
really good for getting
you up and running.
I expect when your application
is working, or you have a
prototype built, you would
actually extract the bits into
separate JavaScript files,
just to be a bit neater.
But it's perfect for now,
for what we're doing.
Well, let's just run
it at the moment.
For now, all it does
is it makes calls
against the plus API.
We're going to extend it
slightly to make calls against
the drive API, but you see it's
exactly the same thing.
So right, firstly, let's install
a virtual environment.
You should really do this if
you're testing stuff out.
I don't want to install flask
for the whole system.
That would be bad.
So we've create call it ve, and
we're going to run pip,
the installer, from inside there
to make sure that it's
installed in the right place.
Install flask.
OK.
So this goes off to py py, and
it will install flask for you.
Really ignore the
warnings, OK.
There's lots of them, but
just ignore them.
Then we also want to install the
Google API Python client.
So we can install
that, as well.
And now these are installed
in my virtual environment.
And I'm actually ready to
run the quick start.
So, ve/bin/python.
I'm running Python from inside
the virtual em, this ensures
that it has the right
environment, the right Python
part, for the libraries.
So ve/bin/python, signin.py.
OK.
And you see that starts it on
all ports, on all hosts on
port four, five, six, seven.
OK.
So let's have a look at that.
And there we go.
So I don't know if
you can see that.
There's a beautiful sign
in button there.
I really like the red
button, but that's
actually for dark themes.
So we have a kind of a light
theme on this blank page.
So, first thing we'll
do is we'll
start to tweak it slightly.
OK.
So let's look at the
source code where
this button is defined.
Well, we know it's going to
be in the HTML somewhere.
Not in their head,
in the body.
And there, we can see it.
OK.
So how do you do it?
Well, you just this chunk
of HTML in your page.
It's remarkably simple.
You have to make sure you've
loaded the library, and the
library will go through and
convert this stuff.
So let's have a look.
Well, one first thing we notice
here is the data scope.
Now, I've been a bit cheeky,
and I went through and I
edited this.
So this is saying, when you sign
in, please, in addition
to asking for the scope for the
profile, ask for the drive
file scope.
So applications will be
authorized to use and access
files in the user's drive.
OK.
So that's the first thing.
Secondly, we'll look
at the access type.
This is offline access.
So this may be ringing like,
we have scopes, we have an
access type.
This is OAuth 2, essentially,
but with a nice front end to
start using it.
OK.
And configurable.
So we see the theme
is there, dark.
So let's set it to light.
And let's refresh this page.
And there we go.
So we have a nice,
white button.
Actually, you know what, even on
this white page, I think I
prefer the dark one.
So there are many, many
parameters for this.
And it's really configurable
how you like.
I like the Google branding.
I think that looks
really nice.
So we just going to leave
that on our page.
And there it is.
So let's start it.
Let's run it.
Let's see what happens.
So the first thing I see is,
I get this pop up button.
OK.
Google Drive sign in app, that's
what I've described
this app as in the API
developer console.
And you can see it's beautiful,
it's really nice.
In addition to the regular OAuth
2 descriptions, where we
have, here, view and manage
files and documents in your
Google Drive-- that's what
you would show if you
used regular OAuth--
we have these extra two parts.
And these two parts, the first
one is allowing your user
information and your circle
information to be accessed by
the application.
So the application doesn't
know what you circles are
named, or anything like this.
They just know the list of
people in that profile.
And I can edit that list.
And you can see that I've
used this button before.
And I'm quite tight
on privacy.
I don't like anyone to know
anything about me.
I certainly don't want this
application to know who's in
my circles.
That's fine.
So I've unselected these.
And this is really nice.
This is actually sticky,
and it remembers
what I did last time.
So I have no circles selected.
OK.
The other part is allowing
people in the circles to see
that I use this application.
Again, I don't really want
people to know, so
I've put only me.
OK.
So this will get my profile
information, but
nothing else, really.
Now, I'm very privacy
conscious myself.
I've told you I hate giving my
information out to people.
And as my friend, Vick Friezel
says, I don't know of an
application that isn't made
better, that cannot be
improved, by knowing something
about the user.
OK.
That is just, I think,
inherent.
So a quality application will
know about the user.
It will be tailored to them.
It will be socially applicable
to them.
So I think that's a really
useful thing.
Let's press accept and
see what happens.
So we accept, and a number
of things happen.
OK.
So, again, this page is showing
what happened on the
authorization, and it's showing
a bit of information
about my profile.
As I say, the app, whatever your
app is, will be better if
it knows about the user.
So how does this work?
Well I've got the Python
Quickstart.
And this is something we
call the hybrid flow
for the sign in.
I've managed to authorize on
the client, in the browser,
and also send a code over
to the server to
exchange for a token.
So I've now got offline access
on the server, and I've got
online access in the browser.
So that's really cool.
I've authorized in
both places.
Now, I like to make
my API calls from
Python, from the server.
That's absolutely fine.
I'm going to do that.
So this loads the Plus library,
makes a JavaScript
call to fetch this profile
information--
and let's have a look
at the code--
and then, goes through and
calls, eventually, after
loading the stuff, a function
called connectServer.
OK.
And here it is.
So what does connectServer do?
Well, it's got the token.
It will send me the token,
the code that I can
exchange for a token.
That's here.
So it's going to post.
And in the body of the post,
it's got the code.
And at the same time, it's going
to pass some state, that
actually, that's built into the
Quickstart really good.
So the Quickstart is using state
to make sure that the
person who's making the request
is actually the person
who initiated it in
the first place.
So that's really good to prevent
all kinds of forgery
and stealing, this.
So it just sends that
to the connect
endpoint on the server.
OK.
So switching back over to the
web application, we can see--
and this is beautiful, this
is why flask is so nice--
we have this route that
is on connect.
And it accepts posts.
OK.
So at some point in this
function, we're going to go
through, and we're going
to make an auth flow.
OK.
And how's it going to do that?
It's going to create an auth
flow in Python, and it's going
to exchange the code.
Just like you would do if you
had initiated the flow
yourself by redirecting
someone somewhere.
So it's basic OAuth.
Uses the same libraries,
but it does the
first half for you.
So that's really great.
So we've got the code.
This will store in a session.
OK.
And eventually, this
will get around to
calling the people endpoint.
OK.
The people endpoint is just a
dummy, there, to show you how
to make an API call
from the server.
So the people endpoint
gets called.
And it adds some information
to the page when it
responds with that.
OK.
So let's have a look at
the people endpoint.
It's a lot shorter,
and a lot simpler.
So we're fetching the
session for the
credentials from the session.
That's where you stored them
from the connectServer point.
And then, as we go down--
this should be familiar to you
if you've ever used the Python
client library before--
it builds a service, it makes
a request, and it gets the
results of that.
OK.
And pumps it back into the
page as a bit of JSON.
OK.
So that's perfect.
So this looks like a good place
where we're going to
start writing our code.
OK.
So firstly, let's build
a drive service.
Drive equals build.
So the name of the API,
which is Drive.
The version of the a API,
v2 is the latest.
And we pass out authorized
HTTP instance in there.
Then, what shall we do?
Well, a simple call just
to get-- let's
get the about feed.
OK.
So I'm going to import the
[INAUDIBLE] printer.
So you can see what happens.
So about equals drive dot about
dot get dot execute.
OK.
And we'll print that
to the screen.
OK.
So that's every time this thing
connects, every time it
asks for the people, then
it should do this.
OK.
So let's try that out.
So we're still signed in.
The app's really nice.
It recognizes that
you're signed in.
It doesn't offer you
the button again.
And if we look, on the output,
you see our about feed.
Now they about feed is something
that happens for all
users in Google Drive.
There's metadata about the user
itself, what roles they
have, what kind of files they
can format, what formats they
can export or import their files
from, their quota, other
information about their
applications,
their permission ID.
This kind of thing that is
useful for your application.
So there we go.
We've just made an API call.
So let's disconnect.
And let's show you.
So, small bit of HTML
to do this.
Calls Google's flow, sends
the code to the server.
The server exchanges the code
for a token and saves the
token in the session.
Then, the front end makes an
Ajax call to the server, and
we see output again.
OK.
So getting the about feed,
that's not that useful.
What if you want to do something
else like, I guess,
make a file.
So file equals--
or let's not call it file,
because that's a
Python built in--
drive dot files dot insert.
And let's see.
Body equals title "Hello
GDL!!" There we go.
Drive dot files dot execute.
And [INAUDIBLE]
that.
So let's do that again.
And this time, it should
be making a file.
Let's have a look there.
That's that.
And then we go.
There's the file that
it's created.
It should have the
right title.
But that's the metadata
output.
Now, in the real world,
what would you do.
Well, you'd pump this back to
the front end, then you'd
display it in a nice way.
Or whatever you wanted
to do with it.
Or whatever your application
does do with Google Drive.
There are 101 use cases there.
So let's have a look in
the Google Drive.
Here's my Drive.
Let's refresh that.
And there we go.
There's our file empty.
Doesn't have anything
in there but
"Hello GDL!!" OK.
So what have we done
here today?
We've shown how you can use the
sign in button for your
Google Drive API application.
OK.
Whether it be on the client,
because this authorizes into
the client, or whether
it's on the server.
Which your application might
be one or the other.
What we haven't talked about
is on the mobile device, on
Android, and iOS, this is
also covered there.
And maybe, soon, we'll have a
GDL showing you how to do
that, as well.
So key points to take away.
Google+ sign in button isn't
just for Google+.
It's for all Google APIs
that use OAuth 2.
And that includes
the Drive API.
OK.
That's the first one.
Second one, it's really
easy to use.
Grab the quick start
for your language.
You will be able
to get started,
literally, in 10 minutes.
I cut a few steps, so it was
even shorter than that.
So yeah, really good.
Please use it.
We recommend that it's the
best way to do it.
It's a nice, branded button.
And we recommend you do that
with your application.
OK.
So thanks very much for
joining me today.
Been really great.
And if you have any
questions, please
follow up on stack overflow.
Thanks very much.
Bye bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]